spring in Rip Hamilton covering the
playoffs if former NBA player college
great as well rip good morning how are
you
the morning then are you doing bro I'm
doing okay good to have you back I was
worried my Booker Fritzi put our IP and
he put it in capital letters and I
thought something had happened to you
but but you are you're good you're
healthy you're safe right
hey I'm healthy I'm saved and actually
I'm still looking for you from that last
interview we did when we actually won
the championship and we still got a bet
going on about you challenging members
you challenged Ben Wallace in a
free-throw contest so oh my god I've
been ready for you so anytime you ready
we can behind the gym wherever you're at
really could still have that bet do you
realize that Ben Wallace retired so he
wouldn't face me and shooting
free-throws hey listen II got a run
around no more he got a block shot
that's all you do now to shoot free
throw
rip what do you want impact on the body
what do you want to put on that okay I
[ __ ] we can what 15 free throws me
against Ben Wallace yes got a $10,000
bet ten thousand all right yes all right
we won't set out we're gonna bring the
camera crew and everything I'm gonna ask
my guys Dan that's who you got money on
me or Ben Wallace I'll put a thousand on
you Dan thank you anybody else want
peace I got you all day all night 3,000
our Wallace what's good to have you back
where do you want to start you want to
start with the Lakers mess you want to
start with the Celtics we can say nice
things about the Bucs if you want to
where do you want to go wherever
wherever you want to go wherever you
want to go okay explain what happens now
in Boston well I think they got a lot of
things to think about one the number one
thing is uh what do you do with Kyrie
Irving this Kyrie Irving don't come back
you know is he going is he going to
commit to a long-term deal with them and
do Danny Ainge feel like a guy reads the
guy that want to get us to the NBA
Finals you know is he can he be the best
player on the best team I think that's
the big question mark for them I think
everything surrounds him if ad if they
decide to
that try to get Anthony Davis I don't
think Anthony Davis comes without Kyrie
Irving I think every Davis want to win
and so I think it's a lot of things that
that they got to talk about in
management to try to figure out what
direction they want to go do they want
to build around Tatum and Rozier and all
the young guys that they have there so I
think it's a lot of question marks with
management well do you want Kyrie Irving
back if you're Boston I would I would I
think that you know I really wanted the
top two best closers in the NBA I think
in order for them to win a championship
you know you can't win championships
with young guys you know you need a guy
that been there before that has
championship pedigree I got it knows how
to win do I think that they need more
vets around him do I think I mean
believe me more guys that that that that
fits kairi's game because you understand
when you look at Boston a lot of guys
they have on that team need the ball
over here nobody plays off each other
that was the luxury that we had in
Detroit was even though chunks he needs
the ball in his hand most of the time I
was able to come off curls dreams I
didn't need the ball in my hand so I was
just trying to find the right fitted
guys to surround Kyrie and if you can go
out and get a guy like ad yeah I don't
want Kyrie I don't want to miss my
number-one guy and I just didn't look
happy and I keep saying he needs a buddy
because I I just it feels like it's it's
him and then it's everybody else on that
team I think Gordon Hayward was a
liability for that team and it sounds a
little crazy to say they were better
last year rip than they are this year
because they played as a team last year
and they played you know as underdogs
this year they didn't do well playing
his favorites like I said before I
thought Brad Stevens had a tough job
this season you know a lot of people
point the finger at Kyrie Irving you
know nobody really points the finger at
Brad Stevens I think you know with the
team he had he had to figure out how to
make that work
you know Kyrie and Gordon had a tough
you know situation becoming so knowing
that the success that these young guys
had last year and this is a different
era basketball right you know young guys
they get out there now and have the
type of success that they had the year
before you know they want to be the
stars they want they want to get paid
they want the max deal yeah so it's hard
to take a back seat knowing that a you
guys you know the young guys performing
as well as they play the year before
that so that's always tough
he's Rip Hamilton he won a title with
Yukon back in 1999 won a championship
with the Pistons in oh four
yes Paulie based off at least 500 career
games played the worst free-throw
shooter in NBA history is Ben Wallace at
41% and I'd hate to tell you but I hate
to do 10 grand out of your pocket you
probably got kids put in college rip I
mean I mean I do I do so hopefully that
can get a man because you know by time
my kids get the cars tuitions gonna be
about 250,000 yeah this is what why
don't why don't you just put up your
championship ring with the Pistons all
right but I can't I don't think I can
allow that to happen if you went into
knowing that you have my ring you know
wearing around saying that this is what
I got off for a pound I don't know you
got to put something up big for that one
Oh
see what can I put up here what you guys
I got all these sports Emmys that I'm
not used and I'll be happy to give those
to you I mean a cluttered all over the
place that might be cute I can put them
up in my office to say that out well
that might be cute nobody's gonna know
the difference you can take off the
plaque there and just put on Rip
Hamilton sportscaster of the year I like
that I like that
I might have to be a bit all right how
did the Lakers get in this position rip
you know what if this whole season has
been a a mess for Los Angeles Lakers and
it's kind of even weird to even think
about that
you know before LeBron James got hurt we
were talking about LeBron James being
MVP was talking about the Lakers being
the top three team in a Western
Conference and then all hell broke loose
once he got hurt and I just think that
now everybody's just playing same
like like when you know they should have
been all in the foxhole together the
Lakers are probably historically the
best franchise that ever existed you
know and to see how magic left the
Lakers and now in the situation you see
with tyronn lue I'm not giving them a
five year deal when you give all the
previous coaches you gave up walking a
five year deal another guy just got a
deal for five years Monty Williams yeah
yeah you're telling me a guy that we got
it won a championship LeBron had great
success with him
and you're telling me you don't want to
hit a five-year deal so it's just it's
been a mess over there would you want to
play for the Lakers if you were in your
prime right now yes I would and the
reason why I say that is because if I
got an opportunity to play with you know
arguably the best player in the game
LeBron James and normai game and knowing
his game I feel like it's a great
situation for me because I'm a well I'm
a well without the ball the only thing I
do is find spots and run the floor and
LeBron James gonna put it right on
target so I just feel like my game fits
his again so okay it will be a situation
that I would love you know if game was
on the line would you rather have LeBron
with the ball or Chauncey Billups rip
I'm just starting to bring the heat we
haven't even got into the into the gym
yet into my dojo I see that I see a man
on man I mean you know I've gotta go
with my man child because that's my guy
you know you
he is so many big shots during our
career so I gotta go with Chauncey I'll
never turn my back on my guys do you
have any masks left I do I got a few of
them in my shoe room at my house where I
got all my memorabilia and my shoes come
here see and everything like that how
many shoes how many parents yeah how
many pair I got yeah thousand thousand
where Joe is the best brand in the world
so they always took care of us so
you know I got thousands I mean I got
peas for days I got all these different
websites trying to get my sneaker closet
to see what I got in there yes it's
pretty cool to see okay if you if you
had to get out of the house with one
pair which pair probably oh that's a
good question
my Jordan my Jordan twos that uh the
owner of the pistol deal when they
retire my Jersey had them dipped in 24
karat gold and I got them in there too
so I think they would probably be the
first ones because the two Jordan tunes
well my favorite sneaker to play in so
he has them dipped in 24 karat gold I
was off I grabbed on foot first you
haven't worn the 24 karat gold Jordans
there's no way yes because there's some
NBA players that look like they were
running around with 24 karat gold
Jordans oh I know I love what the lead
done with the with the sneaker colorways
now because now you allow guys to wear
any color ways don't have to match up
with the team color jerseys or uniforms
or anything like that so I think the way
they're allowed round fashion today is
very cool I want to give you time with
this VR this virtual reality because I
was exposed to this a couple years ago
at the NCAA championship game the Final
Four and we got a chance to see VR
explain what you're doing with them well
it's cool I mean Intel sports uh you
know they came up with this whole
virtual reality where it kind of brings
fans closer to the game and it's cool
because now it allows everyone to have a
front-row seat and you can kind of watch
it from wherever you can watch it from
your living room you can watch it in
your PJs and you can kind of see stuff
that you wouldn't be able to see to see
in a normal telecast and that's the
thing that I love about it because it's
kind of like I'm bringing you in the
locker room with major kind of watching
the game with me and my co-host
Stephanie ready who's done an excellent
job with me but it kind of brings you in
in
in the locker room with myself and we're
just talking we're talking about the
game we're able to see all the different
camera angles so you can see certain
parts of the game that you wouldn't be
able to see in a normal telecast so it's
a great experience it's fun you know I
always tell my kids because I wasn't a
kid that got an opportunity to go to a
lot of NBA games when I was younger so
it kind of gives you that experience
that you're like sitting on the floor
you know we got back to the you got
cameras on the back of the bass on the
back of the basket which is probably my
favorite because it kind of really
brings you inside a game you can't hear
the trash talk and you can see the guys
throwing elbows and you know there's
sort of stuff you can see when you're
close like on the floor that you
couldn't see a few five or six rows up
so it's a great experience I've been
telling people my kids love it
talk to a couple NBA guys their kids
love and that was gratitude for me
because you can see stuff that you
wouldn't be able to see and want to know
Mattel jazz yeah it's a pretty cool
oculus store OCU lus you can download
it's free to download from the oculus
store and you can watch the game in ways
that you never thought were possible
he's Rip Hamilton I like cash instead of
cheque cashier's check yeah cash is king
and if you if you want it good luck
trying to find Ben Wallace I guarantee
you he's not practicing his free-throws
right now after I win you know what I'm
doing after you pay me the money okay
I'm gonna actually send you in the crew
they're a whole bunch of a copy let's go
hand since so then you can pay more
attention to what I'm talking about how
my delicate so they'll know do you
really know what I'm talking about when
I say Ben Wallace can beat you in the
free-throw contest I will wear the
virtual reality goggles while I shoot
free-throws just might you know do it
I'm bringing okay got a bit I'm bringing
heat I'm bringing heat hey I want to
apologize up front to your family for
taking ten grand from you and but it's
great to talk to you that is always
that's Rip Hamilton he won title at
UConn want to title with the Pistons
four more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at